wie sich ein drama zur tragödie
ausweiten kann zeigt sich bild stark an
den flüchtenden aus der ukraine zwischen
vier und zehn millionen menschen so wird
geschätzt könnten oder müssen ihre
heimat verlassen unabhängig von der
dauer des krieges und dessen
verheerenden folgen und das sind dann
unsere flüchtlinge sie sollen und wollen
den westen erst mal in sicherheit leben
rückkehr ungewiss flucht aus der ukraine
was muss europa jetzt tun jetzt in der
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst
migrationsforscher und vorsitzender der
europäischen stabilitätsinitiative esa
und sie waren spiritus rektor des
damaligen flüchtlings abkommens von eu
und türkei
sebastian hartmann ist bei uns von der
spd innenpolitischer sprecher der
bundestagsfraktion und zugeschaltet sind
alexandra bienert eine ukrainische
menschenrechtsaktivistin und
historikerin und schließlich veronika
priesmeier die couch stellvertretende
direktorin der europäischen akademie
hier in berlin bevor wir hier in die
diskussion eintreten zum thema
flüchtlinge schauen wir auf das ereignis
des tages nämlich den auftritt des
ukrainischen präsidenten wolodimir
selensky vor dem us-kongress in
washington nicht leibhaftig sondern per
videobotschaft
[Applaus]
dream ich habe einen traum die scannen
sie alle ich sage zu ihnen heute ich
habe einen bedarf ich brauche sie ich
brauche den schutz unseres himmels ich
brauche ihre
entscheidungsfreudigkeit ihre
unterstützung das ist das gleiche was
sie empfinden wenn sie die worte habe
dream höheren
frau wiener der traum von wolle die mir
selensky
dass er das heißt oder der trauben
lautet mehr handfeste militärische
unterstützung durch den westen wie
sollte der westen auf diese erwartung
reagieren
ja guten abend und danke für die
einladung
ich denke es wäre sehr sehr wichtig für
uns jetzt den himmel über die ukraine zu
schließen weil es handelt sich
tatsächlich um einen russischen imperial
im krieg und russland wird nicht stoppen
russlands an bord unsere städte und
heute war für mich das ereignis des
tages endlich dass das theater in
mariupol mitmenschen drehen mit
zivilbevölkerung mittendrin zerbombt
wurde und russland wusste dass der
zivilbevölkerung sitzt dass das darf so
nicht weitergehen und ja wir brauchen
militärische unterstützung weitere
militärische unterstützung des westens
eine diskussion die ja innerhalb der
nato staaten geführt priesmeier der
polnische ministerpräsident und sein
stellvertreter samt zweier weiterer
regierungschefs aus osteuropa war
gestern zu gast in der ukraine ein
aufsehenerregender und sehr gefährlicher
besuch welche erwartungshaltungen haben
denn diese osteuropäischen kollegen bei
selensky durch diesen besuch geweckt
auch guten abend von mir ich glaube das
war eine enorme symbolische gäste bisher
war das so dass die lenski immer nach
außen ausgestrahlt hat an verschiedenen
konferenzen an verschiedenen aussprachen
teilgenommen hat aber mit dieser reise
von den drei regierungschefs und
natürlich auch weiteren personen ist
europa in die ukraine gekommen auch wenn
es gefährlich war auch wenn es natürlich
nicht logistisch einfach war waren dass
das wichtige gespräche die wirklich vor
ort in kiew passiert sind und das passt
so ein kleines bisschen auch in dieser
symbolik so was ähnliches haben wir
erlebt auch 2008 in tiflis in georgien
während des russisch georgischen
krieges dann waren damals auch eben die
mittel und osteuropäischen
regierungschefs und vertreter dort
einfach die solidarität mit
dem volk und auch natürlich mal mit den
ländern zu zeigen und deutlich zu machen
ihr seid teil von europa ist teil von
uns und deswegen kommen wir hier und
sprechen uns direkt face to face in
unter vier augen oder unter mehreren
augen und dass das macht was aus das ist
ein wichtiges zeichen sowohl eben für
die politiker als auch für die
gesellschaften und das sieht man auch
deutlich in der ukraine bis zum krieg
und wahrscheinlich jetzt auch
waren die zum beispiel bei der polnische
präsident der berühmteste oder
beliebteste politiker und runter unter
den anderen europäischen regierungschefs
das heißt diese verbindung diese
sympathie dieses dieses gefühl okay wir
verstehen uns und wir wissen was um uns
herum passiert das ist durch solche
gesten natürlich auch noch bestätigt
worden genau aus was zielinski vom
westen erwartet wird die ja alle
höchstwahrscheinlich eine verschärfung
der situation bedeuten eine eskalation
auch in wie auch immer ein solche
militärischer eingriff dann aussehe und
das wetter ja auch zu folglich
möglicherweise die flüchtlingszahlen
weiter anschwellen
also da bin ich nicht sicher ob diese
kausalität so besteht denn die
flüchtlingsbewegungen die wir gesehen
haben sind das direkte ergebnis der
kriegsführung von wladimir putin es ist
die
unfähigkeit städte zu schützen es ist
das ziel seiner politik das war es schon
in früheren kriegen das weiß in
tschetschenien 2000 in der ost ukraine
seit 2014 und das weiß in aleppo als
seine truppen und seine luftwaffe vor
allem assad bei der rückeroberung von
aleppo so unterstützt haben dass die
stadt zur geisterstadt wurde millionen
vertrieben ich glaube mir putin hat er
kann der hat sich getäuscht die ukraine
sind eine eigene ein eigenes volk eigene
identität sie kämpfen auch die
russischsprachigen ukraine wollen nicht
von seinem russland beherrscht werden da
hat er sich getäuscht aber jetzt greift
er zu den instrumenten des terrors und
er hat gleich zwei ziele ein ziel ist
natürlich die ukraine durch terror dazu
zu zwingen seine bedingungen anzunehmen
und das zweite ziel
sicherlich auch aus den erfahrungen der
letzten jahre ist durch eine große
millionen starke flucht in die
europäische union zu hoffen dass das die
europäische union überfordert und dass
die europäische union dann auch auf
seine erpressung 1 1 geht hat man da
will ich gleich waren anschließen krieg
und jetzt die flüchtlinge die kommen als
folge dieses krieges besteht die gefahr
einer destabilisierung weit über die
ukraine hinaus
flugbewegungen haben die stabilisierende
wirkung auf nachbarstaaten und direkter
anrainer staaten das haben wir bei
anderen konflikten gesehen aber die
antwort europas ist eine andere als in
anderen konfliktlagen einerseits ein
ganz geschlossenes vorgehen ein klares
signal des westens dass wir dieses
vorgehen verurteilen sanktionen aber
auch verteidigungsmaßnahmen für die
ukraine in dem waffen geliefert werden
wir haben ein bundeskanzler der von
einer zeitenwende gesprochen hat und wir
erleben einen mechanismus in europa der
durch die richtlinie die den temporären
schutz gewährt ganz vieler menschen der
aktiviert worden ist in einem
einstimmigen europäischer solidarität
polen hat 1,8 millionen menschen
aufgenommen das ist ein signal dass
innerhalb von rekordzeit gesetzt und wir
reden vom tag 21 einer militärischen
auseinandersetzung wie wir sie so auf
diesem kontinent nicht gesehen der
versuch ich stimme da ausdrücklich zu es
ist teil der kriegsführung auch vor
keinen zivilen einrichtungen vor kein
krankenhäusern schulen und anderen
schutzräumen halt zu machen führt zu
einer direkten flucht befinden wir reden
über millionen von kunden vertrieben
aber den druck nimmt europa auf auch in
einem akt der solidarität
wir kommen auch auf die verhältnisse in
polen jetzt speziell was sie gerade
angesprochen was die flüchtlinge angeht
vor allen dingen dort ankommen aber frau
beer zunächst mal blick nach deutschland
jeden tag kommen in berlin glaube ich
bis zu 10.000 flüchtlinge an soweit wir
das wissen im moment
scheint ja die betreuungs und
versorgungslage noch gut zu sein stoßen
wir an unsere grenzen sie sind ja selbst
in der flüchtlingshilfe in berlin tätig
ja zunächst einmal wollte ich noch sagen
zu ihrer vorherigen frage dass wir in
der tat gestern auch jemanden aus der
deutschen regierung in der ukraine
vermisst haben mit den anderen
vertretern der staaten das muss man
einfach sagen ich habe mich gefragt wo
ist da der vertreter eigentlich
deutschlands warum ist da auch nicht
zusammen mit den vertretern die schon
benannt wurden nach kiew gereist oder in
die ukraine gereist wir haben hier das
ist so eine komische haltung wir haben
so eine gespaltene halten einerseits
haben wir in deutschland unglaubliche
solidarität und das erlebe ich jeden tag
es ist eine offenheit unglaublich
aufenthalt aber andererseits kann kann
deutschland sich irgendwie nicht bis zum
ende dazu bewegen auch auch
außenpolitisch wie der ukraine sich so
zu solidarisieren dass wir das auch sehr
stark fühlen und auch auf ihre frage zu
antworten ja also wir haben in der tat
kommen jetzt jeden tag schätzungsweise
das kann übrigens keiner von uns auch
wissen weil es sehr es werden nur busse
von der polizei geschätzt und züge es
werden nicht zum beispiel menschen mit
gezählt die privat mit den autos
abgeholt werden und so wie ich das jetzt
über blicke werden jetzt die meisten
oder viele ganz ganz viele menschen mit
den autos privat abgeholt so habe ich
das auch mit dem teil meiner familie
gemacht sodass das man autos seien
einfach organisiert die bis zur grenze
fahren und menschen abholen das kommen
offiziell offiziell mehr oder weniger
offiziell 10.000 menschen an
wir haben jetzt tatsächlich
ein problem mit der unterbringung es ist
bekannt viele menschen fahren nach
berlin
langsam sind auch die kapazitäten
natürlich war wir wissen jetzt dass sich
27.000 menschen erst mal registriert
haben beziehungsweise termine bekommen
haben aber es sind auch viel mehr und
welche erfahrung ich mache und was ich
sehe vor allem auch sagen möchte wir
müssen uns klar werden wir sprechen
jetzt über diese ganz großen dimensionen
es geht um ganz konkrete menschen es
kommen menschen zu uns die traumatisiert
sind ich war vor einigen tagen mit
seiner frau unterwegs und ich habe
kirche gezeigt öffentliche einrichtungen
zeigen dann sagt sie mir ja ich habe
überlegt ob in dieser kirche und wir
befinden uns in kreuzberg
einen luftschutzkeller gibt das müssen
wir uns erst mal vor augen wir haben
hier menschen die die sehr sehr
traumatisiert zu uns kommen und es ist
wichtig das wird in der tat sie auch
weiterhin so solidarisch empfangen und
ja ich weiß dass berliner ganz ganz
vieles macht und vieles liegt noch auf
den schultern von ehrenamt jetzt kann
aber können ja nicht alle flüchtlinge
die nach berlin kommen auch in berlin
bleiben selbst wenn viele hier gerne
bleiben wollen sie müssen verteilt
werden die verteilung ist im winter hat
man noch ein bisschen privatsache das
wird von ehrenamtlichen oft organisiert
da müssten eigentlich bund und länder
die dafür ja von amtswegen zuständig
sind eigentlich viel mehr tun warum
geschieht dann noch so wenig jedenfalls
hat man das gefühl dass so wenig
geschieht wir sind seit einigen tagen in
die verteilung gegangen man muss sehen
dass diese situation sehr dynamisch war
in den ersten tagen gegenüber tausende
von menschen gesprochen insbesondere
aber auch in die direkten anrainer
staaten haben die besonderheit das ist
ja eine vielzahl auch persönlicher
beziehungen existieren wie wir es gerade
gehört haben gerade auch in polen wurde
schon 15 millionen ukrainer lebten bevor
es zu den kriegerischen angriff den
völkerrechtswidrigen angriffskrieg kam
und so ging es auch in den ersten tagen
in deutschland und wir haben es
geschafft im zusammenspiel zwischen den
ländern und den kommunen tatsächlich
über zukunft verfahren plätze zu
organisieren da wo keine beziehungen
existierten oder möglicherweise
unterbringung gesucht wird das haben wir
verändert wir sind jetzt in einer
verteilung dass die länder zugewiesen
bekommt das ist notwendig weil wir jetzt
von 175.000 registriert menschen stand
heute wissen und darüber hinaus auch ein
mechanismus aktiviert haben den wir
schon kennen aus
2015/2016 wenn wir eben über
länderquoten die feste verteilung sind
und berlin ist ein zentraler anlaufpunkt
auch aufgrund von internationalen
fernverkehrsverbindung sind müssen
berlin entlasten eine großartige
leistung auf vielen dank auch an die
ehrenamtlichen helferinnen helfer aber
uns ist bewusst dass ist keine
dauerlösung und darum sind wir jetzt
schon ein tag 20 an einer situation dass
wir etwas aktiviert haben was sonst ja
wir haben jetzt von 175.000
registrierten flüchtlinge
gesagt sind wahrscheinlich mehr ist zu
einer million werden geschätzt kommen
allein nach deutschland sind noch mal
fünf bis sechsmal so viele herr klaus
die verteilen sich ja nicht von alleine
gibt es da noch ein defizit was die
verwaltung angeht was muss da jetzt
passieren wie muss man sie zumindest
jetzt innerhalb deutschlands erst mal
verteilen also ich glaube zunächst muss
man sich der dimension bewusst sein also
wir reden von einer million menschen in
der woche die in den letzten drei wochen
in die europäische union kam das sind in
einer woche so viele winter gesamten
flüchtlingsbewegung 2015 im jahr
und 2015 haben alle menschen gesagt hat
eine unglaubliche herausforderung
mobilisieren wie schaffen wir das eine
million im jahr das in den nächsten zwei
wochen werden wahrscheinlich wenn es so
weitergeht noch einmal zwei millionen
menschen in die europäische union kommen
wir haben die situation wo in warschau
bereits 300.000 menschen sind laut
bürgermeister wenn man das auf
deutschland hochgerechnet wären das in
deutschland 18 millionen menschen
ungefähr also man muss sich der
dimension bewusst werden wenn jetzt in
den nächsten zwei wochen noch mal zwei
millionen menschen kommen dann ist
relativ klar die werden nicht in
moldawien bleiben können das land ist
voll sie werden auch nicht mehr
anlaufstellen in polen finden in polen
das ist eine unglaubliche zahl die schon
aufgenommen wurde sie werden entlang der
verkehrswege mit bahn zug bus
auto versuchen alle nach deutschland zu
kommen deutschland oder österreich
wenn das zwei millionen sind in zwei
wochen dann reden wir in kürze über eine
herausforderung die deutschland seit den
40er jahren nicht erlebt hat und
tatsächlich ist mein gefühl in den
ländern ist immer darauf vorbereitet auf
das niemand ist davor gehörte niemand
kann darauf vorbereitet sein weil ich so
etwas noch nie gab aber was jetzt da ist
ist das bewusstsein ich spreche mit
vielen ministern auch in den ländern in
den letzten tagen da wird schon darüber
nachgedacht die messe ist es um
abzusagen die messehallen mit betten
auszustatten alle kapazitäten zu
mobilisieren man sieht es ist möglich in
warschau man sieht vor allem es ist
möglich mit den vielen ehrenamtlichen
und da muss man dazu sagen
ohne die ehrenamtlichen ist es undenkbar
dass das funktioniert das ist etwas was
nur staat und gesellschaft zusammen
machen können ohne die angebote aber
zurück zur verteilung ohne eine
verteilung auch in deutschland wird es
auch nicht gehen es ist unmöglich dass
so viele menschen jeden tag 10.000 jetzt
in berlin in berlin unterkommen man wird
sie verteidigen zusammen donnerstag
sollen wollen sich die
ministerpräsidenten der länder mit der
bundesregierung treffen da geht es
eigentlich um corona aber das ist auch
ein wichtiger punkt vielleicht noch ein
kurzer aspekt bevor wir uns der
europäischen seite zuwenden oder der
europäischen dimensionen stichwort
finanzierung es muss im moment viel
finanziert werden verteidigung corona
klima tank rabatte auch ist was die
unterbringung die integration von
flüchtlingen aus der ukraine in
deutschland angeht ist denn die
finanzierung gesichert nach ihrer
kenntnis wir müssen sie sichern und das
ist auch eine erfahrung der jahre 2015
2016 ich möchte keine 34 gipfel
wochenenden hintereinander haben wo
jedes mal nach gesteuert wird wir
brauchen ein ehrliches bekenntnis dazu
das ist unsere gesellschaft fordern wird
aber wir wollen dass es ist staat und
gesellschaft es wird geld kosten und das
auf eine sache nicht passieren dass 2015
2016 passiert ist dass man vergisst dass
die kommunen eine hauptlast tragen was
unterbringung aber auch integration und
beschulung und sozialer infrastrukturen
gibt deswegen fordere ich auch ganz klar
dass wir den anfang auch sagen dass wir
das über den föderalen staat finanzieren
und verantworten dass wir das klar
machen und dass wir auch darüber
sprechen dass selbst wenn heute der
waffenstillstand verkündet würde und ich
sage putin stoppen sie diesen krieg das
ist die ursache er muss diesen krieg
stoppen er kann den befehl geben dann
wird aber nicht an der situation seien
bei zerstörten städten zerbombten
wohnblocks dass die menschen zurückgehen
können wir reden hier darüber dass wir
über monate oder jahre eine situation
haben die europa insgesamt fordert das
sollten wir ganz klar kommunizieren
offenes wort aber wir wollen das weil es
auch eine frage unserer werte und
überzeugung ist dass wir diesen
angriffskrieg nicht zum erfolg führen
lassen dürfen und dass wir verkennen
dass das auch in den letzten jahren eine
enorme herausforderung war aber es sehr
lange gedauert hat das anzuerkennen das
müssen wir anders machen
folglich war ja wir haben es gerade von
gerald knaus schon gehört diese
dimensionen diese zahlen die
möglicherweise in den nächsten wochen in
form von menschen von flüchtlingen die
hier schutz suchen auf uns zukommen
polen kennt diese zahlen bereits dort
sind glaube ich mit stand heute etwa 1,8
millionen flüchtlinge angekommen direkt
aus dem nachbarstaat ukraine die stabil
ist die lage vor ort eigentlich in polen
angesichts dieser dieser vielen
flüchtlinge die da
inzwischen dass sich in polen zunächst
mal niedergelassen haben
die lage ist
vielleicht nicht stabil aber die lage
ist nicht kritisch und das ist glaube
ich wichtig um das festzuhalten und ich
würde dem alten zustimmen was sie gerade
dann auch gesagt haben es ist eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe und wir
merken natürlich und wirklich anhand von
polen können wir sehr gut sehen was sind
denn die einzelnen schritte bzw was
gemacht werden muss weil zu anfang ist
sehr stark eben die zivilgesellschaft
aber auch vor allem die ehrenamtlichen
an den start gegangen und natürlich auch
die städte und kommunen rund um die lage
zu stabilisieren beziehungsweise den
menschen so gut wie möglich zu helfen
und sie auch eventuell auf die
weiterreise zu schicken beziehungsweise
sie auch zu unterbringen wird man kann
und am besten wie man kann und jetzt ist
es tatsächlich mal die frage okay was
passiert konkret natürlich ist auch die
europäische unterstützung sehr sehr
wichtig aber polen ist anders als
deutschland keine förderer start
deswegen ist es ja auch keine
selbstverständlichkeit dass die gelder
sehr schnell wirklich mal an die
kommunen an die städte fließen durch den
zentralen aufbau des staates kann es
sein das ist natürlich zu verzögerungen
kommt nämlich dass das alles zentral
geregelt wird deswegen würde ich schon
sagen sehr wichtig ist in diesem
zusammenhang zu schauen dass die
prozesse sehr schlank sind dass die
hilfe da ankommt wo sie gebraucht wird
und dass man natürlich eben dieser
dieser entlastung schafft denn die
ehrenamtlichen helfer und unterstützer
die sind tatsächlich auch sehr sehr
erschöpft das höre ich immer wieder von
menschen denen nicht nur in warschau
aktiv sind sondern auch in breslau und
in anderen städten irgendwann ist sind
ist die kraft einfach raus irgendwann
haben wir das gefühl so okay es geht
nicht wir wir können natürlich auch
diesem ausmaß der
tragödie
auch nicht mehr verkraften wir brauchen
da selber natürlich auch unterstützung
das sagen mir so oft meine meine freunde
und meine meiner kontakte in polen
deswegen es ist natürlich wichtig jetzt
ist es an der zeit dass das ein bisschen
stärker auch geregelt wird auch
natürlich politisch aber viel viel mehr
administrativ und was ich auch nicht
vergessen dürfen und das war jetzt ein
bisschen auch deutlich in diese reise
nach kiew
ist nämlich in polen ist trotz der pokal
des ukraine krieges und trotzdem
flüchtlings der nach wie vor eine
situation einer spule einer politischen
auseinandersetzung und fast nahezu eines
wahlkampfes auch wenn möglicherweise die
wahlen in polen wie geplant erst im
nächsten jahr stattfinden sollten ich
würde immer wieder gesprochen dass sie
möglicherweise vorgezogen werden oder
sie noch in diesem jahr stattfinden
können und das hören sie und das merken
sie ganz deutlich das unter der dem
thema ukraine krieg und natürlich auch
die flüchtlingskrise weil so müssen wir
das hier auch nennen wir auch
gleichzeitig mit politischen
auseinandersetzungen und politischen
kämpfen zu tun haben und das wird sich
natürlich mal wiederum auf das thema
verteilung unterstützung meiner zelle
hilfe auswirken
ganz konkret in der letzten zeit in den
letzten jahren ist die unterstützung für
die indios sehr stark reglementiert
worden
das heißt viele angels können einfach
mal nicht wirklich diese unterstützung
leisten wie sie vorher leisten könnten
und jetzt ist es an der zeit auf der
europäischen ebene wirklich mal dieser
gelder so zu verteilen so möglich die
unterstützung zu machen das ist wirklich
auch funktioniert dass die
flüchtlingspolitik eines landes
auswirkungen auf wahlkämpfe haben kann
haben wir in deutschland erlebt nach
2015 bei der bundestagswahl 2017 frau
bienert
wir haben jetzt in deutschland die
situation dass sehr viele flüchtlinge
kommen der staat will finanzmittel zur
verfügung stellen das feld dem deutschen
staat relativ leicht es gibt aber länder
die sehr viel mehr viel klinger
hunderttausende ukraine aufgenommen
haben die wirtschaftlich etwas schwächer
dastehen moldau rumänien ungarn slowakei
frau priesmeier hat das gerade schon
gesagt wie muss die europäische union
jetzt da helfen gerade dort wohne hilfe
vielleicht nicht so gut organisiert
werden kann wo nicht so viel geld da ist
wie in deutschland
ja ich denke europäische union sollte da
solidarisch handeln das ist das eine und
wenn wir über die eu hier sprechen
müssen wir unbedingt auch die
aussenpolitische wirkung ansprechen und
zwar dass die eu hätte ich die ukraine
und da verlasse ich ganz kurz mal das
thema geflüchtet sie hier richtung
rheine eine signal senden soll oder muss
signal der beitrittsperspektive es ist
ganz ganz entscheidend und das ist das
heißt gar nichts dass die ukraine morgen
hier in der eu mitglied sein wird das
ist nur dass wir eine perspektive
bekommen und irgendwann bis 20 25 dann
in die eu drin sind das ist jetzt
unabhängig jetzt von der frage von der
solidarität die von einzelnen staaten an
andere ausgehen kann was ich nur sagen
könnte ist dass es in der tat wichtig
ist über die integration nachzudenken
und da wäre es wichtig dass das hat auch
schon ein redner vorher gesagt es wird
so sein dass menschen nicht so
durchgehen können anderthalb millionen
die aus archiv kommen das ist eine
größere stadt in der ost ukraine und hat
gewisse zerbombt werden nicht
zurückgehen können manche werden hier
bleiben und wir müssen tatsächlich
schauen wie wir menschen bei der
integration helfen können wie wie
qualifizierung von einzelnen erziehern
und lehrern gleich stellen können und
wie wir insgesamt auch mit sprachkursen
und mit sonstigen kitas und schulen
umgehen können da sehe ich auch ein
handeln auf der gesamteuropäischen ebene
notwendig und insbesondere natürlich in
deutschland diese integrationsfragen
wollen wir gleich noch ansprechen er
klaus ganz kurz noch zu der verteilung
und jetzt im eu-rahmen da haben sie sich
ja auch schon gedanken gemacht wie sie
denn eine faire verteilung aus innerhalb
der europäischen union das hat ja mit
den flüchtlingen aus dem nahen und
mittleren osten nach 2015 nicht sehr gut
geklappt sind denn alle länder jetzt
auch angesichts dieser schlimmen bilder
aus der ukraine auch der geografischen
nähe der ukraine zu uns in der alle
länder der europäischen union gleich
aufnahme freudig oder gibt es da auch
unterschiede wie muss man das jetzt auf
der europäischen ebene handeln wir haben
ja eine sehr interessante situation ein
großer unterschied zu 2015 und das ist
dass die die ukrainerinnen die hier vor
allem frauen mit ihren kindern kommen
überall in der eu sofort eine
aufenthaltsgenehmigung bekommen also man
braucht jetzt nicht mehr darüber
verhandeln wenn eine stadt wie madrid
sagt wir nehmen
fünfzig oder hundert tausend und
liesborn dublin stockholm dann muss der
staat nicht mehr zustimmen die dann ist
die frage nur wie kommen die menschen
die in polen oder in
moldau in die eu kommen wie kommen die
dorthin wie organisiert man das und das
was wir haben ist solidarität in vielen
ländern in großbritannien gab es einen
aufruf der regierung eine frage wer die
leute aufnehmen 80.000 haben sich an
einem tag gemeldet
das muss man allerdings jetzt
organisieren die
innovationen ich glaube die ukrainische
community die schon in europa lebt die
irgendwann mal als arbeitsmigranten
hergekommen die sind ja in viele länder
in europa verteilt also es gibt in
italien in spanien gibt es glaube ich
dann wie viele im vereinigten königreich
so nicht nur in köln und in deutschland
aber und ich glaube das ist extrem
wichtig schauen wir uns noch einmal die
zahlen an wenn in den nächsten zwei
wochen und ich sage das in einer woche
in der woche ist hätte ich darüber rede
ist eine million gekommen in den
nächsten zwei wochen zwei millionen
menschen kommen und wir davon ausgehen
eine million geht nach österreich und
deutschland das wären unglaublich viele
deutschland würde unglaublich viel
machen müssen damit das geht die andere
million die wir nicht in polen oder
moldau bleiben also ist dann die frage
schaffen wir es dass frankreich spanien
auch vielleicht großbritannien die leute
aufnehmen das heißt aber konkret im zwei
wochen müsste frankreich dann sagen wir
nehmen 160 und 200 tausend menschen auf
konkret ich glaube ich jeden bewusst was
das heißt logistisch praktisch leute
kommen an man musste nicht einmal zu
überzeugen wir haben hier flugzeuge
busse wir fliegen das wäre nach
frankreich ungefähr 550 flüge in zwei
wochen wir fliegen euch nach paris nach
leo nach bordeaux und dort muss die
bereitschaft sein die leute aufzunehmen
wenn das nicht klappt und wir reden hier
von tagen dann sind noch einmal eine
million die
in europa herum ehren und die gefahr
dass wir frauen mit kindern haben die
auf der straße leben auch wenn
deutschland sich so mobilisiert wie noch
nie in seiner geschichte und viel mehr
als 2000 15 die besteht also die frage
ist wie schaffen wir es diese empathie
und da brauchen wir eine andere
organisation wir brauchen jetzt endlich
bereitschaft da bei den anderen ländern
die sie jetzt genannt haben auch hass
links zahl von ukrainischen flüchtlingen
und ich bin überzeugt die bereitschaft
ist da aber was uns fehlt ist die
organisation diese empathie mit logistik
zu etwas machen wo leute auch hin finden
und da brauchen wir eine struktur die
wir nicht haben alle strukturen die wir
den letzten jahren gesehen haben war zu
schwerfällig wir bräuchten jetzt einen
koordinator oder ein team von
koordinatoren ich schlage vor ehemalige
hohe politiker premierminister die
anrufen können die kommunizieren können
und die sagen können das spanische
ministerpräsident pedro sanchez ist
spanien bereits 100 leute aufzunehmen
und in spanien organisiert man dann
lokal welche städte welche verbände sind
hotels bereit es gibt initiativen alle
hotels zwei familien aufzunehmen das
wäre in spanien schon sehr viele plätze
aber irgendwer muss diese anrufe machen
und muss dann sagen spanien nimmt
100.000 leute auf wie werden die darin
gebracht vom flughafen in yashin im
osten rumäniens wer macht das und diese
koordination der zeit habe ich noch ein
bisschen das gefühl wir warten wer wer
kopf kriegt welchem zug wie viele züge
gibt es eigentlich jetzt aus rumänien
nach österreich nach deutschland
wo kommen die leute unter wir schauen
dann noch ein bisschen zu viel zu er hat
man deutschland ist weil es auch
fluchtpunkt ist wahrscheinlich da auch
besonders gefordert bei dieser
koordinierung hunderte von flugzeugen
bussen zügen zu organisieren ist das dem
gehörten bei uns klar es geht nicht nur
um die verteilung in deutschland sondern
auch die weiterverteilung in andere
europäische länder was auf uns dazu
kommen die gesagt deutschland ist
besonders im viele kommt hierher
entweder nach polen oder nach
deutschland das ist ja eine enorme
logistische herausforderung auch
die situation ist uns bewusst auch wenn
wir innerhalb von 21 tagen ein
zeitraffer der situation
2015/2016 erlebt haben aber wir haben
eine kollektive erfahrung in europa dass
wir die phase 2015 2016 nicht noch mal
wiederholen wollen es ist die erste
signal wäre ja schon gesetzt wurden
einerseits mit der aktivierung des
mechanismus der übrigens 2001 schon
existiert hat aber damals nicht gezogen
worden ist über den temporär handschutz
der gewährt worden dass auch
drittstaatsangehörigen in der ukraine um
deutlich zu machen dass wir dieses teil
diesen teil der kriegsführung menschen
zu objekten zu degradieren nicht nur zu
ermorden sondern tatsächlich
fluchtbewegung aus was zuvor auch schon
belarus und polen versucht worden ist
dass wir diesen teil nicht mitmachen und
der zweite schritt denn nun auf
europäischer ebene gipfel struktur
stattfinden muss auch mit den
innenministern der findet hier statt
indem nämlich jetzt eine akte
europäischer solidarität das ist auch
heute noch mal im bundestag aktuell
diskutiert worden getan wird in dem eine
solidarische verteilen ist muss in gang
gesetzt wird lassen sich aber auch
darauf hinweisen dass sich die position
deutschlands in sofern klar verändert
hat dass die neue innenministerin nancy
faeser
ganz klar an den anfang ihrer amtszeit
gesetzt hat wir müssen uns der frage der
migration zu wenden sie hat bevor es
überhaupt zum angriff der ukraine auf
die ukraine kam schon mit den
innenministern anderer europäischer
staaten gesprochen gesagt wir brauchen
einen neustart zu europäischen
asylsystems wir brauchen eine neue
regelung der frage von migration und
wenige wochen danach kam es ja zu diesem
völkern die wahrscheinlich in dieser
größenordnung nicht gerechnet hat
niemand rechnet mit einem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff der mit
einem knopfdruck die nachkriegsordnung
1975 helsinki zerschlägt in europa und
so viele menschen in die flucht treibt
dennoch wir können da nicht ausweichen
die situation ist gegeben und sie wird
jetzt entweder mit einer frage der
europäischen solidarität beantwortet ich
bin trotz der dramatik der situation
beeindruckt davon wie schnell das
gelungen auch wie unbürokratisches
gelungen ist ein pragmatismus der in
europa plötzlich an den tag gelegt wird
der bei zwingend notwendig ist wir
müssen die situation auch anders herum
zu ende gelingt es uns nicht ist dieses
europa basierend auf werten auf
augenhöhe auf einstimmigkeit prinzipien
passé das hat eine rückwirkung auf
unsere gesellschaften auf unsere
struktur auf unsere demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit das was gelingen
kann ist ja auch ein neuer dialog
zwischen den staaten europas oder
gekommen sind auch mit osteuropa zu
einer neuen verständnis und werden einen
geeinten blick auf russland und diesen
angriffskrieg möchte an dieser stelle
auch noch mal klar sagen es ist putins
angriffskrieg es gibt mutige
journalistin journalisten kollegen von
ihnen die sagen nein zum krieg ich will
das nicht wir wollen das nicht es gibt
auch eine zivilgesellschaft die sich in
russland formiert und trotz der höchsten
strafen die dort drohen nun zeigen es
gibt auch eine gegenbewegung die müssen
wir stark machen und das ist jetzt die
bewährungsprobe möglicherweise etwas was
putin ja gar nicht beabsichtigt hat also
genau das gegenteil von dem gott sei
dank passiert ist was er möglicherweise
beabsichtigt hat frau bin hat es ist
jetzt hier schon mehrfach angeklungen
die frage ist die die aus der ukraine
flüchten flüchten die auf dauer flüchten
die vorübergehend es ist ein aufenthalt
auf dauer ein vorübergehender aufteilt
wie ist denn die stimmung und das gefühl
der unter den ukrainern die jetzt
geflüchtet sind glauben sie dass sie
relativ bald wieder zurückkehren können
unter dem der voraussetzung dass der
krieg zu ende ist dass sie nicht mehr
bedroht werden dass der wiederaufbau
beginnt oder glauben viele dass das ein
abschied für immer aus der ukraine ist
also zunächst muss ich auf meinen
vorherigen redner antwortet der gesagt
hat wenn mir das aufgeschrieben niemand
rechnet mit einem rechtswidrigen angriff
auf eine stadt da muss ich leider
widersprechen weil sie haben einen krieg
in europa seit 2014 und wir schreien
überall darüber herum wir haben
russische panzer dieser 2014 in der ost
ukraine rollen wir haben annektierte
creme und wenn das für sie keine wir
singen angriff darstellt dann weiß ich
auch nicht warum warum sagt denn dass
siemens chef ja das sind ja zum polit
turbulenzen in geschäftsbeziehungen zu
kann man das doch nicht weitermachen
also ich zunächst bis ich auf ihre frage
antworte möchte ich hier tatsächlich
eine intellektuelle ehrlichkeit von
deutschland verlangen wir können nicht
mit einer hand zivilgesellschaft in der
ukraine jahre lang in der tat jahrelang
und danke dafür auch an deutschland
unterstützen und andererseits
trotz der annexion der creme trotzdem
menschen selbst verletzungen auf der
krim trotzdem was in der ost ukraine
passiert ist und da ist da schon 2014
der krieg rollt einfach weiterhin aus
dem eis und zwei bauen die noch drei
letzte kanzler und inklusive
entschuldigung auch ein scholz der ende
dezember sogar noch gesagt hat nord
stream was dem einen ist ein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt nein alle
alle haben damit gerechnet und vor allem
wie er ich kann seit 2014 nicht gut
schlafen mittlerweile ist ja alles
schlimmer eingetreten und ihren nun
zurück zu ihrer frage
menschen wollen natürlich zurückgehen
wie sie wollen installieren sie kommen
erst mal an sie haben sie kennen die
sprache nicht sie kommen auch so damit
sie es vorstellen können warum es anders
kommt zu uns schon auch fachkräfte es
sind ja also fast alle kommen haben auch
eine ausbildung oder eine
hochschulausbildung
sie haben aber sie kann mit einem koffer
kleidung erstmal weil man hat vier
minuten oder 30 minuten im besten fall
um warm einzupacken und eigene katze in
die tasche zu stecken und dann raus zu
fahren unter dem beschuss um zum glück
überlegt man das und sie kommen an und
vor allem was was wovon wo ich auch ganz
viel gefragt werde ich werde jetzt nicht
gefragt kabinett vollkommene vier
leistungen beantragen ich werde ganz oft
gefragt hast du hast du arbeit für uns
wir wollen hier arbeiten und das ist das
was auch jemand vorher schon gesagt hat
müssen diese menschen auch als subjekte
sehen da sind menschen menschen die auch
in der gesellschaft sobald es uns
gelingt das vielleicht mit der
integration zu machen und auch ganz wien
beitragen können
natürlich können wir es jetzt nicht
vorhersehen ob sie nun dauerhaft bleiben
ich kann nur sagen einerseits besteht in
großer wille zu so kommen andererseits
kann es sein dass sie es nicht mehr dass
sie ihre stadt nicht mehr haben werden
wo sie zurückgehen können und dann
müssten wir tatsächlich ganz klare
integrative maßnahmen
ergreifen was bedeutet das für die
integration die frage erst mal man weiß
nicht genau wie lange diese menschen
bleiben sie wissen es selbst nicht
manche möchten zurück manche vielleicht
gar nicht mehr nach diesen erfahrungen
was bedeutet das für die integration in
für die integration in den arbeitsmarkt
für die integration der kinder in die
schule für das alltagsleben für die
wohnungs beschaffung dass wir haben sie
ja die grössenordnungen gehört sechs bis
siebenstellige zahlen werden da jetzt
gehandelt was bedeutet das für die
integration dieser menschen bei uns also
ich würde davon ausgehen dass in diesem
moment fast alle zurückkehren wollen
weil ihre männer brüder väter sind ja in
der ukraine und kämpfen dafür dass
dieses land diese demokratie auch die
identität des landes erhalten bleibt
aber es ist auch klar wenn es wladimir
putin und seiner armee gelingt noch mehr
gebiete zu erobern noch mehr
terroristische sogenannte volksrepublik
anzuschaffen oder das land zu teilen
dann werden nicht nur die menschen die
hier sind bleiben sondern auch ihre
männlichen verwandten zu uns kommen denn
unter wladimir putins dunkler herrschaft
die ja in den letzten monaten in
russland noch dunkel wurde wird keiner
leben wollen das heißt wir wissen jetzt
die leute wollen zurück sollten aber
davon ausgehen dass wir die zeit diese
hier sind so gut wie möglich nutzen und
ich mir sehr gut gefallen dass der
sächsische ministerpräsident gesagt hat
er hat gesagt alle die die jetzt zu uns
kommen die kinder die frauen vor allem
sollen sich egal ob sie zurückkehren
oder nicht wenn sie alle waren die
ukraine zurück kehren ihr ganzes leben
lang daran erinnern wie sie hier
aufgenommen wurden es geht jetzt darum
dass die kinder die er traumatisiert
sind herausgerissen aus ihrem leben so
schnell wie möglich in die schulen
kommen selbst wenn sie nur zwei jahre
hier sind ich habe selbst töchter die in
vielen verschiedenen ländern in die
schule gegangen sind das war immer eine
gute erfahrung wenn sie das gefühl haben
sie werden aufgenommen und die sympathie
die empathie in der gesellschaft führt
dazu dass das möglich ist je mehr frauen
und wir brauchen ja auch diese
ukrainerinnen wir brauchen jetzt
lehrerinnen wir brauchen jetzt
psychologinnen wir brauchen menschen die
uns helfen bei der unterstützung der
flüchtlinge viele haben qualifikationen
je schneller die arbeiten können selbst
wenn sie dann in zwei jahren oder in
einem jahr oder vielleicht hoffen wir in
einem halben jahr zurückkehren könnten
wir müssen davon ausgehen jetzt sind sie
da und je schneller und rechtlich ist
das ja zum glück sofort möglich wenn wir
die bürokratie zurückfahren wenn wir
wenn die behörden flexibel sind ich weiß
hier in berlin wird das probiert die
ausländerbehörden sind überlegen schauen
was man alles elektronisch beantragen
kann wie man schneller
arbeitsgenehmigungen vergeben kann ganz
deutschland ich glaube der wille ist da
das zu tun das ist für alle gut für
deutschland und für die menschen auch
unter den flüchtlingen flüchtlingen sind
die schwächsten die
gern auch noch mal ganz kurz ist ist
sehr wichtiger punkt was sie gesagt
haben herr klaus nämlich es ist wichtig
glaube ich zu sagen dass diejenigen die
die hier sind die sind jetzt teil
unserer gesellschaft das ist nicht nur
die ukrainische diaspora also leute die
hier gekommen sind und dann einfach mal
weiter hin doch in der ukraine drin sind
sondern das wie sie in den deutschen
schulsystem integrieren oder in andere
europäische schulsysteme dass wir sie
ebenfalls in den arbeitsmarkt und in das
gesellschaftliche leben mit aufnehmen
wir haben in deutschland bereits diese
erfahrung gemacht die negative
erfahrungen mit der anderen
herangehensweise nämlich mit türkischen
gastarbeiterinnen in den 60ern und 70ern
jahren wo wir sehr stark davon
ausgegangen sind acht lassend die
einigen diejenigen die nur für ein paar
jahre gekommen sind und dann gehen sie
irgendwann zurück weil deswegen war es
nicht notwendig sprachunterricht in
integration integrative maßnahmen und
andere auch formen des
gesellschaftlichen zusammenlebens zu
investieren diese fehler dürfen wir
jetzt wirklich nicht wiederholen denn
die ukrainischen geflüchteten sind jetzt
hier diese die möchten auch teil dieser
gesellschaft sein und da müssen wir und
das ist ganz ganz wichtig nicht nur als
verwaltung nicht nur als staat sondern
wirklich als gesellschaft weil diese
aufgabe nehmen und und einfach mal
schauen okay wir können wir zusammen
leben und was können wir gemeinsam
machen was können wir auch voneinander
lernen denn es gibt glaube ich eine
menge die beide seiten ich würde gerne
noch ein aspekt ist tatsächlich glaube
ich auch der mehrere dörfer auf die
schwächsten auch unter den flüchtlingen
sind die kinder
einschulung bildungssystem integration
in die schule die schulen bei uns sind
schwer gebeutelt durch die pandemie
vielleicht ganz kurz wir nicht mehr so
lange zeit wie kann man diese doppelte
aufgabenstellung bewältigten einerseits
die schäden durch die pandemie
beseitigen und gleichzeitig viele kinder
die jetzt dringend schulbesuch brauchen
bei uns aufzunehmen wir sind in einer
doppelten herausforderung krone hat
diese gesellschaft auch verändert
gestresst und gerade die kinder sind
diejenigen die da meisten unter gelitten
haben deswegen muss man auch da offenes
und ehrliches wort wählen da sind auch
viele soziale verwerfungen entstanden
die es gibt ein an den weg ist es jetzt
ist möglichst pragmatisch und
unbürokratisch anzugehen deswegen gibt
es auch nicht fünf oder sechs stellen zu
denen man laufen soll sondern einfach zu
erkennen es gibt jemanden der da ist er
wird registriert das führt zu arbeits
zugang bei meinem arzt wegen alter ist
das führt aber auch zu
lösungsmöglichkeiten mit den ländern
deswegen auch gemeinsam bund länder und
kommunen geben das nicht auf der ebene
zu verschieben zu sagen dass ein problem
der kommunen problem der länder
zueinander kraftakt ich habe einen
anderen starken auch pragmatische
lösungen gesehen wir sollten in
deutschland einen zweiten teil auch
anders man hat 2010 auch akzeptieren
eine zweitbeste lösung zu wählen
hauptsache wir haben eine lösung dieses
umfeld erlebe ich sehe den beitrag der
politik genau diesen rahmen zu schaffen
würde ich auch engagement so ganz gern
als robin hat ganz kurz wir haben
wirklich nur noch wenige sekunden zeit
ist das problem der integration vor
allem die sprache gerade bei kindern wie
kann man das am schnellsten lösen
ja ich denke wir haben das auch schon
bei willkommens klassen gesehen dass es
ganz kurz klappt die hauptsache wir
lassen diese wenn ich alleine und wir
versuchen alle möglichen bürokratischen
hürden auch web zu machen nur dass diese
kinder einfach in die kitas und in die
schulen in die willkommens klassenkampf
und mehr aus mit einem weiteren stühlen
klassen und mit der schaffung von neuer
klasse und natürlich auch mit der
gleichstellung der qualifizierung von
lehrerinnen und lehrern die astro kräne
gekommen ist gut dass muss jetzt
notgedrungen etwas unfertig und
rudimentär heute sein da sind wir erst
am anfang einer entwicklung ich bedanke
mich bei
alexandra bienert bei veronika
priesmeier der coach und hier im studio
bei gerald knaus und weil sebastian
hartmann liebe zuschauer morgen in der
phoenix runde
rekordzahlen bei corona lockerungen um
jeden preis morgen ist ja dass bund
länder treffen eine reihe von kona
maßnahmen sollen ja am kommenden sonntag
auslaufen da gibt es großen politischen
streit jetzt folgt felix der tag mit
meyer reber darin das was wir heute in
der sendung auch gezeigt haben der
auftritt von ohne die mir selensky vor
dem us-kongress und einiges mehr gerade
zum krieg in der ukraine bleiben sie
baut
[Musik]